Speaker 1: Last thing I want to touch on with
Carrie Lake, just the hilarity of the final
people insisting that she would win, even though
it was clear she didn't have the numbers. Carrie
Lake herself and other extremists insisted she
was going to win until the very last moment. At
a certain point, you have to ask, do they not
understand basic math? Do they not understand
the degree to which they need to overwhelm
the remaining ballots the further they fall
behind? And don't they realize, wow. I haven't
gotten 60% of the vote anywhere so far. I need
60% of everything that's left to win. It's
probably over for me. They don't seem to get
it or they don't care. Let's go through this.
Here is Kerry Lake. Up until the last moment,
look at how confidently she insisted, I'm
going to win. I'm going to win. Do you find.
Speaker 3: It somewhat.
Speaker 2: Problematic at all that
your opponent, Katie Hobbs, is secretary
of state and she didn't recuse herself?
Speaker 1: By the way, this happened in
Georgia previously where the secretary
of state was running for governor, that
they none of these Republicans had any
problem with it. Now they have a problem with it.
Speaker 2: Overseeing this election, an election
that she's actually very much running in.
Speaker 3: Yes, I did. As a matter of fact,
right after I got into the race, after threw my
hat into the ring in June of 21, that next month
in July, I recognize that would be a problem.
Yeah. And we put out a very hard push for her
to recuse herself from any aspects of her job as
secretary of State that oversaw any part of the
elections as she refused to do so. And we saw how
botched the August 2nd primary election was. Much
of that can be attributed to her incompetence.
And now we're seeing all the problems with this
election. And I think it's just going to well,
when I win, it's going to be a sigh of relief.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, that was
that was yesterday. And indeed,
the sigh of relief was that Carrie Lake lost.
Here's Marjorie Taylor GREENE talking about
that critical Arizona race. Just yesterday.
Speaker 3: We lost in 2020 because of that,
because of the mail in ballots and because it was
ripe for election fraud. And now we're watching it
again, especially. And Kerry likes race over
in Arizona. This this shouldn't be this way.
Everyone was calling for a red wave. Either
all the pollsters were wrong and they need to
be fired and that's Republican or Democrat.
Speaker 1: And I mean, that's what they've
been saying forever. These Republicans forever
have been saying fire the pollsters, the.
Speaker 3: Media pollster saying that we
were going to get a red wave or we have to
finally acknowledge the fact or at least we
have to get the other side to acknowledge the
fact and admit the truth that mail in ballots
is the biggest problem in our elections.
Speaker 1: Mail in ballots are the biggest
problem in our elections. So Marjorie Taylor
GREENE jumping full speed ahead into the fraud
element. And she says, listen, all these right
wing pollsters told us there was going to be a red
wave. Now, there wasn't. It must have been fraud.
It must have been fraud. And then here is January
six. Riot organizer Ali Alexander saying that he's
going to will carry Lake to win. This was just
yesterday morning. Hours later, she lost.
Speaker 2: Even if
Kerry was going to lose. I would will it
into existence. And I know that sounds kooky.
Yes. And I know that sounds crazy.
Yes. Don't catch me on a wild day, huh?
Pete Davidson one time got on my bad side.
Yeah. Almost killed himself. So what? You're
not going to believe me. It doesn't matter. The
point is, is that no one needs to believe you the
first time. The point is, you just need to tell
them the first time. Okay. You understand this?
No. This is going to sound kooky for young Cosey.
But you guys don't understand the esoteric. Oh.
What if I told you that all of us are
capable of traveling? Well, not all of us,
because you're not smart enough. But what if I
told you that there are a lot of people capable
of time traveling? They just don't know
it. What if I told you that time traveling?
It's easier than you think.
Speaker 1: Yep. Well, this is
exactly the caliber of person that was supporting
Kerry Lake. So, you know, whether it's because it
was willed or prayed for or someone traveled
forward in time or back in time, Kerry Lake
has lost and we can all rejoice. It is a bullet
dodged. Huge work to be done over the next two
years. Make sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel. A lot of people, 3.2 million last month,
watched our videos, didn't subscribe to the
YouTube channel. Make sure you hit that subscribe
button. Help us get to 2 million and we will
take a very quick break and be back after this.